avec nous ce soir benjamin amar
professeur d'histoire porte parole cgt
94 bonsoir benjamins à vos côtés francis
palombie président de la confédération
des commerçants bonsoir vous font 6
plombier
enfin alexis poulain éditorialise
bonsoir alexis poullan alors les
conférences de presse de jean castex est
devenu le rendez vous incontournable du
jeudi avant de recueillir l'avis des
secteurs concernés 1 par ces annonces ce
soir avec six poulains globalement quand
vous a inspiré ce cru du soir où là
alors c'est vrai elle nous manquait
presque un ces conférences hebdomadaires
ils sont passés maîtres dans l'art de
prendre beaucoup de temps pour dire pas
grand chose des annonces qu'on
n'attendait pas puisqu'il n'y en a pas
eu quasiment 1
le fait que les écoles vont rouvrir à
date fixe comme l'a dit emmanuel macron
ils sont là pour meubler pour boucher
pour donner finalement quelques éléments
de langage celui du soir s'était
renforcé un des mesures renforcées on a
entendu sinon c'est le flou total et
puis une nappe et délits mais ce soir je
souhaite un bon anniversaire à d'autres
miss de la santé s'était et 41 ans
d'olivet vers ans aujourd'hui voilà
c'était peut-être pour ça qu'il ya eu
cette conférence de presse histoire de
fêter le coup un peu différemment avec
jean michel blanquer remise de
l'éducation qui étaient là également on
a l'impression que tout est là pour
gagner du temps pour faire croire qu'il
se passe quelque chose et puis surtout
pour écouler les stocks de vaccin parce
que clairement dans quelques temps les
vaccins astrazeneca risque d'être
périmés et il faut les injecté avant
cette catastrophe parce que là les 20
millions et les 30 millions enfin on va
en parler sans doute des objectifs
vaccinaux ne seront jamais atteindre
dans ce cadre là oui on en parlera dans
quelques instants alexis on va essayer
détaillé les points importants quand
même de cette conférence de presse un
rentrée des classes donc bien confirmé
lundi avec un protocole très strict et
un renforcement massif des tests quatre
cent mille tests salivaires dans les
écoles élémentaires et le nouvel outil
ya enfin l'autotest 1 pour les lycées je
vous propose d'écouter
olivier vers en avant de vous faire
réagir benjamin et nous avons désormais
conformément à l'avis du conseil
scientifique les autotests qui viennent
compléter cette stratégie de dépistage
c'est un outil qui va être utile qui
complète notre arsenal existants mais
qui ne va pas remplacer les tests pcr ni
les tests antigénique c'est une très
belle opportunité de nous aider à
maîtriser davantage l'épidémie alors que
nous travaillons à pouvoir rouvrir
progressivement les lieux de vie à
compter de l'animé depuis le temps qu'on
en parle et ça y est on les a maintenant
c'est autotests vous voilà rassurés m'a
jamais vous allez pouvoir vous auto
testé avec les lycéens pour reprendre ce
que dit monsieur poulin je ne sais pas
si c'était la fête d'anniversaire de
monsieur virant ou si c'était encore une
fois une mauvaise version d marrakech du
rire mais moi je n'en peux plus de ces
de ses conférences de presse qui sont
des exercices de communication
c'est insupportable alors écoutez je
sais pas si vous soulevez ces familles
pour mais on avait déjà discuté des
tests il ya déjà quelques mois de cela
où j'étais très dubitatif vous m'aviez
dit mais c'est vrai mais vous m'aviez
dit mais attendez c'est à la rentrée et
c'est alors à la rentrée on a vu ce que
ça avait donné ce qui se passe c'est que
alors que moi j'entends les chiffres
astronomiques du premier ministre mais
moi dans mon établissement scolaire le
moment du dépistage a été ridicule pour
une raison très simple il faut l'accord
des familles il ya énormément de
familles qui n'ont pas donné leur accord
dans le monde réel c'est comme ça que ça
se passe en macro ni dans dans
l'hyperespace macro nist ya une version
est dans le réel dans la vraie vie il ya
une autre test a pas de test je connais
plein de colère il n'y a pas eu de test
du tout hein
vous avez raison nous celle où je vous
dis il ya eu une campagne vraiment de
2,2 de test mais ça a été ridicule parce
qu'il ya énormément de familles qui
n'avaient pas fait leur tour qu'ils
n'avaient pas donné leur accord
voilà et ça c'est entre ce que vous
dites c'est à dire des endroits où il ya
rien
et des endroits où il ya eu mais la
réponse des familles a été extrêmement
marginale eh ben on est dans un délire
et la nouvelle trouvaille c'est
l'autotest alors c'est quoi
à la rentrée moi je vais arriver avec
mes élèves et on va tous se faire une
séance d'auto test dans les narines
sincèrement vraiment je ne sais plus
quoi dire moi les bras m'en tombent
je sais le gouvernement kamoulox chaque
semaine il ya une nouvelle idée là
j'entendais ce que vous disiez vous ils
sont en train d'évoquer la fin du défunt
le fait qu'on puisse à nouveau se
déplacer de manière inter régional et en
même temps il met en place des
quarantaines enfin je pourrais te dire
après nous avoir dit pendant des mois
qu'il pouvait pas mettre en place des
quarantaines il ya des signaux
contradictoires en permanence on dit une
chose une semaine plus tard on dit autre
chose et ça sur tous les sujets je pense
que les français sont définitivement
totalement déboussolée avec ce
gouvernement
alors y'a pire y aller les commerçants
c'est encore moins franco maire son
activité culturelle sport et terrasses
ouvriront me mais si et seulement si
c'est le problème du si la situation le
permet francis ce pas longue vie comment
les commerçants vivent t-il ce manque de
visibilité
vous attendez j'imagine autre chose
peut-être ce soir
écoutez madame je vais vous répondre
un petit peu à l'image de mes collègues
concernant ce soir nous concernant pas
d'annoncé fracassante
le président de la république allait
commencer à donner un calendrier et on
avait oui que à la mi mai une
réouverture était envisageable
ça semble vouloir être le cas nous y
tenons plus que particulièrement parce
que certains de mon commerçant je porte
les très petites entreprises sont à
l'épuisement
alors c'est vrai que j'ai eu peut-être
j'ai vécu cette impunité un exercice
peut-être plus probants et surtout plus
intéressant j'ai créé j'ai eu
l'autorisation et d'un webinaire de deux
heures avec le ministère de la laine
grise et et de son conseiller
mais bien sûr j'ai demandé à ce que nous
passions en revue toutes les mesures
d'accompagnement est ce qu a été fait et
beaucoup de questions ont été posées
cash par les entreprises que je porte
que je représente
il y avait plus de soixante dix
représentants d'entreprises et de
fédérations et effectivement ce qui
ressort c'est que au niveau des aides
peut être certainement quand même le
paysage est un peu plus rassurants que
l'aspect sanitaire parce que 1re enfants
des aides est prévue avec des
aménagements nouveaux on n'est pas au
bout de toutes nos demandes et je le
précise également mais disons que
c'était incontournable c'est inévitable
si il y avait rupture ou retrait sysmans
retrait des aides ce serait la
catastrophe
alors bien évidemment il ya des
commerçants qui ne n'ont pas pu attendre
jusqu'à maintenant pour résister
malheureusement il ya eu de trop de
licenciement pour l'instant et surtout
de faillite
mais pour autant
l'inquiétude était grande alors les
commerçants veulent réouvrir à tout prix
l'incertitude de ces derniers jours les
a mis en colère je le dis également
ils voulaient en savoir un peu plus n'en
savons pas beaucoup plus certains m'ont
demandé de demander la réouverture au 3
mai je ne leur ai dit que c'était peine
perdue
compte tenu qu'un même que nous devons
toujours considéré en tant que citoyens
responsables la spécialité mais je pense
que la réouverture autour du 15 mai nous
préférerions que ce soit le plus tôt
possible
cissé à l'ascension cissé avant si c'est
à partir du 10 mai ce serait encore
mieux
je ne me contente pas trop mais il ya
quand même la notion d'ouverture et
maintenant nous allons rester très
attachée à un calendrier précis qui va
être confirmée par le président de la
république a apparemment très très
prochainement et nous sommes en train de
tout mettre en oeuvre bien sûr
d'accepter certaines contraintes mais
deux c'est seulement qu'on puisse dire
parce que jean castex a précisé la liste
n'est définitivement pas fixé sera
assorti de conditions particulières le
cas échéant territorialisée qui évolue
au fil des étapes on aura l'occasion de
préciser ça c'est très flou quand même
alexis poulain on imagine que pour
certains c'est compliqué parce que oui
les aides perdure m'enfin et en a qui
ont le couteau sous la gorge c'est on
imagine catastrophique pour beaucoup de
commerçants et notamment des
restaurateurs qu'on a souvent entendu
ici même un oui non mais vous vous
imaginez comme on se fait balader depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois mais
maintenant disons avec toujours ces
objectifs qui sont données qui sont
jamais tenues c'était 4 à 6 semaines il
y a huit semaines de cela c'était dans
un mois c'est maintenant me mais on
parle de 800 mille emplois on parle de
d'entrepreneurs qui ne savent pas
comment l'avenir va être fait en parle
de dead aussi qu'ils vont être
débranchées progressivement
bruno le maire qui provisionne déjà 7 à
8 milliards de non remboursement des
prêts garantis par l'état c'est-à-dire
des faillites
on parle de plus de 120000 faillite qui
sont déjà en préparation avec les
liquidateurs et une réforme de l'ag
qui va faire que en plus l'argent qu'ils
payaient les salariés va payer les
liquidateurs plutôt que les salariés
tout ça est en cours et rien n'est fait
pour éviter le mur des faillites éviter
le mur de l'incertitude parce que pour
beaucoup de restaurateurs ça veut dire
quoi
recommencer à zéro avec l'incertitude
aussi du retour des gens finalement
restaurant le fait qu'il n'y aura pas de
touristes comme les autres d'année même
si on ouvre pour la saison estivale
ce ne sera pas une saison estivale comme
les autres donc elles seront les aides
et jusqu'à quand et le combien ça coûte
au final qui va le payer c'est le coi
qui va nous en coûter quoi qu'il va en
coûter aux entreprises et je crois que
le la colère elle elle est réelle
l'agacement il est il est permanent et
là avec ses conférences de presse qui
nous sortent toujours les mêmes choses
avec dû renforcer avec des tests avec
des stratégies mais improvisé sur des
coins de naples avec le cabinet de
conseil pour nous prendre pour des
hamsters un coup on sort de la cage un
cours entre qu'est-ce qu'on prépare
réellement je crois que là aujourd'hui
tout est misé sur une stratégie de
vaccination avec ses 20 millions de
doses 30 millions de doses pour dire
qu'on va retrouver impotent d'une
potentielle vie normale mais ce ne sera
jamais une vie normale on aura le
derrière ce top cow vide tout senti
comme une je sais pas comment ça
s'appellera le fameux pass sanitaire
peut-être pour aller au restaurant
mais on marche sur la tête on aura le
masque à peu près partout tout le temps
puisque le vaccin ne n'empêche pas les
gestes barrières et puis on aura
convient de rappel par an il sera elle
prépare déjà le rappel pour la fin de
l'année et puis chaque année il y aura
des rappels alors ça veut dire quoi que
le monde d'avant il est mort et enterré
et qu'on va vivre maintenant sous
couvre-feu permanent avec ce pass
sanitaire avec cette incertitude
permanente
voilà la question auquel aujourd'hui je
crois aucun responsable politique en
europe ne peut répondre particulièrement
ici en france où on marche vraiment sur
la tête puisque ça n'a été que des
ordres contradictoires et et des amendes
et des amendes parce que à 19 heures il
fallait rentrer chez soi le couvre-feu
19 heures bon je crois qu'on peut
arrêter il fait jour il fait bon on va
peut-être décaler un peu parce que la
raison c'est manifestement moi
j'aimerais moi j'aimerais j'aimerais
savoir quel est l'intérêt de ce
couvre-feu maintenant aujourd'hui voilà
donc je crois qu'à un moment il va
falloir poser le décaissement service
maintenait alexis le problème juif n
importe c'est évidemment la vaccination
parce qu'on a vu comment ça se passe et
au royaume uni
un calendrier qui a pu être respecté et
donner surtout grâce à une campagne de
vaccination réussi malgré tout olivier
verront reste optimiste et nous annonce
des chiffres 1 30 millions à la mi juin
le problème on le connaît aussi en
france et la confiance par rapport à
l'astra et des cas et alors là on sent
que tout le monde rame d'astrazeneca qui
est sur toutes les lèvres
je vous propose d'écouter jean castex
beaucoup de vaccins ont été développés
ils sont utilisés dans les différents
pays du monde
seul un petit nombre ont été autorisés
en france et en europe sur la base d'une
évaluation et d'un suivi rigoureux qui
nous permettent d'en garantir
l'efficacité et la sécurité
c'est le cas du vaccin astrazeneca dont
l' agence européenne du médicament et la
haute autorité de santé françaises ont
encore réaffirmé récemment qu'il était
aussi efficace contre les formes sévères
que le finder ou le moderna je vous
rappelle que nous comptons encore 11
millions de personnes de plus de 55 ans
qui n'ont pas encore été vaccinés
j'ai 55 ans et je me suis vacciné avec
l'astra zeneca comme 200 millions de
personnes dans le monde
benjamin amara vos collègues qui sont
désormais prioritaires depuis que 55 ans
vous leur conseillerais de les faire se
faire vacciner avec ce sérum parce que
c'est vrai que on en a en france a pour
être l'une des premières solutions
médias voilà beaucoup de défiance ronde
s'est alors d'abord moi je suis
syndicaliste et enseignant je suis pas
médecin donc je vais conseiller
personnes par contre je vais vous dire
une chose très simple
moi j'ai eu donc le coc vide sous une
forme grave
et comme je fais de l'hypertension
artérielle justement je suis
particulièrement sensible sur sur cette
maladie donc j'ai cherché à me faire
vacciner rapidement
mon médecin m'a fait un certificat et il
m'a dit une chose monsieur amar vous
avez 45 ans surtout vous ne vous faites
pas vacciner à l'astra zeneca ça c'est
aussi encore une fois ce qu'on dit dans
la vraie vie et vous savez mon médecin
traitant c'est un très bon médecin
il est très bien une suite depuis des
années j'ai jamais eu
il faut il faut donner aussi cette
opinion là le royaume uni a plutôt
réussi sa campagne de vaccination et le
pilier s'est-elle astrazeneca d'accord
moi y'a pas de soucis je vous dis moi ce
que me dit mon médecin traitant dans la
vraie vie quand je moi j'ai aucun
problème à me faire vacciner
et si et donc je vais voir mon médecin
traitant et j'écoute bêtement ce qu'il
me dit voilà et jodie vous faites
vacciner ou pfizer ou au modern amepa
l'astra zelekha voilà et donc à écouter
que voulez vous après on peut on peut
s'étonner du fait que dans la population
en france on prenne pas pour argent
comptant tout ce que dit monsieur castex
où tout ce que dit monsieur véran en
même temps il ya un an d'expertisé
moi je vous le dis franchement je leur
confierait pas mon peigne est par contre
quand mon médecin il me parle et eybens
et j'ai tendance à écouter
donc moi je vais conseiller personnes
pour aller faire vacciner à l'astra cvca
je vais est conseillé aux gens d'aller
se faire vacciner ça c'est certain
et après à chacun verra dans ce que dans
l'opinion qui se fait avec le personnel
médical qu'il a autour de lui
voilà est juste une chose si vous me le
permettez par rapport à ce qu'a dit
alexis poulain juste avant je pense
qu'il ya là quelque chose d'essentiel
parce que la situation sanitaire c'est
important la situation sociale aussi et
quand il évoque notamment puisqu'on
parlait des commerces
madame borne à elle vient d'évoquer le
fait que sur le chômage partiel
il y allait avoir une baisse de la prise
en charge par l'état et donc une hausse
de la prise en charge par les employeurs
et que la rémunération des salariés
allaient passer de 84 à 72 % donc bien
évidemment derrière on va avoir une
vague de licenciements désastreuse est
ce qu'à dit monsieur poulin sur la js
c'est à dire la réforme de la gs est à
dire la réforme de la garantie des
salaires quand on a une entreprise en
liquidation judiciaire c'est extrêmement
important
ce gouvernement vient de de fragiliser
totalement la garantie sur les salaires
au moment où on va avoir une vague de
licenciements et de pse et il faut
rappeler que au mois de janvier ce
gouvernement à réformer l'aide au
logement pour avec 700 millions d'euros
d'économies sur le dos des allocataires
au logement voix
ce que fait ce gouvernement en situation
de pandémie il baisse les aides qui
protège contre la précarité et ça c'est
un véritable scandale
on va se retourner vers le président de
la confédération des commerçants francis
palombes vous vous partagez cette
crainte dit par benjamin à marla
garanties notamment sur les salaires la
fragilisation de tout un pan de
l'économie
c'est évident que monsieur main même
raison de formuler des propos de grande
prudence et de grandes interrogations
c'est vrai que l'aspect social est quand
même très important
alors les entreprises que je porte ont
le nez dans le guidon concernant
également un aspect sur lequel je vais
me montrer très très très très vigilant
c'est les stocks
vous savez qu'une entreprise qui est qui
est restée fermée il ya eu un petit
problème une entreprise une entreprise
qui est restée fermée pendant plusieurs
mois
eh bien les stocks se sont accumulés les
factures arrivent et doivent-elles payer
donc il y à un élargissement des aides
c'est vrai que vous me trouvez peut-être
ce soir très attaché et nous ne sommes
pas les commerçants des mendiants et des
mendiants dead
nous voulons travailler servir nos
consommateurs faire revivre nos
centres-villes bien évidemment mais là
je suis un peu moi même vraiment sur le
sujet permanent au quotidien sur
l'attribution des de renforcer ça a été
le cas cet après midi dans les propos du
conseiller du ministre qui a participé
pendant 45 minutes à la rencontre et
nous avons apparemment je dis bien
apparemment parce qu'un prix il faut que
les faits se concrétise
nous avons été quand même entendu et
nous nous avons pu faire valoir des
aménagements et des renforcements dead
pour certaines typologies d'entreprises
ce qui n'était pas le cas actuellement
nous avons demandé également des
contrôles très sévères et on va nous en
donner la preuve d'après ce que m'a dit
le ministre concernant des grandes
surfaces qui n'ont pas respecté les
règles des produits nos naissances
etc ont continué à les vendre malgré que
les magasins en centre ville étaient
fermées donc voyez nous sommes dans une
grande vigilance
nous devons collaborer avec l'état
évidemment nous avons besoin days c'est
assurément mais il faut il faut être
présent et très très vigilant sur les
chiens peuvent se cacher merci francis
palombes merci également à benjamin
marais alexis pour l'heure d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce décryptage suite à
cette je ne sais plus d'ailleurs énième
j'allais là comptez vous pouvez
l'heureuse énième conférence de presse
du jeudi merci à tous les trois